this video is sponsored by nordvpn which
I'll tell you more about in a bit
Manifest Destiny the term coined in 1845
which endorsed the idea that God
destined the United States to expand its
dominion and spread its values of
capitalism and democracy from the
Atlantic to the Pacific this triggered a
massive westward migration as scores of
pioneers left the safe and familiar
surroundings of the Eastern United
States to stake their claim on a piece
of land out west and of course the
California Gold Rush spurred things on
significantly just a year later in 1846
87 American settlers went into the
Sierra Nevada mountains looking to cross
them and make their way to California
only 48 made it out alive trapped in the
snow with not enough food and supplies
many of the settlers perished falling
victim to disease starvation and
freezing temperatures others decided
that they were willing to do anything to
survive to ward off the Grim Specter of
death they engaged in the ultimate taboo
cannibalism
thank you
in 1845 an Irish immigrant named James
Fraser Reed grew discontent with his
life in Springfield Illinois born in
1800 in County Arma Reed came to America
as a young boy alongside his widowed
mother as an adult he worked hard and
steadily grew his fortune so that by the
time he was in his mid-40s he was a
successful businessman with a large
family and a prosperous farm he was also
pretty bored in Springfield most other
people would have been over the moon if
they had everything Reed had but for him
life simply lacked that certain
something that gave it Pizzazz but Reed
knew where he would find it California
long distance migrations were all the
rage in America back then first there
was The Great Migration of 1843 when a
thousand Pioneers hitched up their
wagons and left Missouri to settle in
the Oregon territory then there was also
the Mormon migration which saw the
Mormons flee from the Midwest to escape
persecution and find a new home in Salt
Lake Valley in Utah and last but
certainly not least there was the Gold
Rush which prompted scores of miners 14
Niners to make their way down California
way in the hopes of striking it rich
James Reed intended to be one of those
settlers who ventured into the dangerous
unknown looking for Fame and Fortune but
he had a tough task ahead of him back
then those who wanted to reach the
Pacific coast had two basic ways of
getting there and neither one was
particularly enjoyable or fast the first
was by sea but this was before the
Panama Canal was built so those who
attempted this journey had a long Voyage
ahead of them as that around Cape Horn
at the southern tip of South America and
then sail back up north the other option
was by land but again this was before
the Transcontinental Railroad so
Travelers had to resort to Overland
Trails through the treacherous
mountainous regions of the American
frontier the Oregon Trail was the
preferred route for this method of
transport it was well traveled but as
the name suggested it took you to Oregon
there was also the California Trail but
this one was still being developed and
Pioneers had not yet found the optimal
route but James Reid was not concerned
with such Minor Details you see he heard
of a guy named Lansford Hastings an
early Pioneer who traveled to Oregon and
California in 1842 and then wrote the
book the immigrant's guide to Oregon and
California he presented the Hastings
cut-off a shortcut that supposedly
shortened the trip by 300 miles and had
it joined the California Trail towards
the end so that Travelers finished their
journey in Northern California instead
of Oregon there was just one problem
though Hastings was talking out of his
ass not only oh is his cut off longer
than the regular more established Trail
but it went through rough Mountain
terrain and the Great Salt Lake Desert
Hastings had never done that route when
he wrote about it nobody had he traveled
only a portion of it on Horseback with
other men who were traveling light he
didn't have a full Wagon Train in tow
with women and children if such a
caravan were to attempt to cross the
Hastings cut off it would be a
guaranteed recipe for disaster have you
ever found yourself scrolling through
travel sites dreaming of a getaway only
to find that the price is different when
you come back to the same website later
well nordvpn is a solution for you
nordvpn is a virtual private Network
that can help you save money on travel
by allowing you to access lower prices
than are not available in your own
country now the best part is it's legal
and acceptable to buy tickets and book
holidays while connected to a VPN server
and that's what all nordvpn can also
protect your privacy and enhance your
online security so if you're looking to
book your next vacation while keeping
your online identity secure nor VPN is
the way to go I've been using nordvpn
for ages I have to say it's really
impressive service it's easy to use just
download the app and connect to a server
in another country and you're good to go
and it's also very quick you won't even
notice that you're using a VPN it also
comes with a 30-day money-back guarantee
so it means you can try it risk free
plus they've got great other features
there's threat protection which Shields
you from malware trackers and ads great
if you're worried about getting hacked
then you've got dark web monitoring
which notifies you if someone leaks your
credentials and then there's mesh net
which allows you to connect to your
devices remotely and securely as well as
dedicated IP which helps you avoid
captures and block lists and it doesn't
end there they've also got a password
manager and a data breach scanner so
what are you waiting for go to
nordvpn.com buy it to get a two-year
plan plus four months on free and start
saving money on your travel bookings
today don't forget it's risk free
there's a link below and now back to
today's video
[Music]
despite the perils and uncertainties
James Reid had found a pair of
like-minded individuals who wanted to
make the trip with him Brothers George
and Jacob Donna like Reed they were
prosperous Farmers so what exactly
possessed them to pack up their whole
families and March through the Untamed
Wilderness well we'll never know they
were also significantly older than the
middle-aged read George Donna was 60 and
his brother was 56 and of course both of
them had large families mainly
consisting of children under 10. and so
on April 14 1846 The Donna Reed party
left Springfield Illinois the initial
group numbered 31 people and consisted
of James Reid George and Jacob Donna
their entire families plus a dozen also
employees and Teamsters which were
animal drivers they made their way to
Independence Missouri nicknamed the
Queen City of the trails because it was
a departure point for many of the trails
to the Pacific coast in early May the
party reached the city but they were
already cutting it pretty close you
might think that they had all the time
in the world since it was still spring
but Travelers on these Trails were on a
pretty tight schedule to ensure that the
pack animals found plenty of grass to
eat on the way that's why late Oprah was
the standard cut off for starting these
trips fortunately for The Donna Reed
they arrived in time to join the last
Wagon Train of the Season it would be a
close shave but good conditions would
get them to California in four months of
course as we all now know the journey
they were about to undertake was
anything but good conditions to be fair
the first part of the voyage was
pleasant and easy going everyone was
left awestruck by the many wonderments
of nature that they encountered daily
and the Knights were filled with singing
dancing games and the kindliest feelings
of good Fellowship there were around 50
wagons in the party although suffice it
to say that none of them were quite like
the Reed wagons which James Reid had
custom built girly he spared no expense
as evidenced by the description provided
by Reed's stepdaughter Virginia she
wrote are wagons or the Reed wagons as
they were called were all made to order
and I can say without fear of
contradiction that nothing like our
family wagon ever started across the
plains it was what might be called a
two-story wagon or Pioneer Palace car
attached to a regular immigrant train
the entrance was on the side like that
I'm an old-fashioned Stagecoach and one
stepped into a small room as it were in
the center of the wagon at the right and
left were spring seeds with comfortable
High backs where one could see it as on
the seats of a Concord Coach in this
little room was placed a tiny sheet iron
stove whose pipe running through the top
of the wagon was prevented by a circle
of tin from setting fire to the campus
cover aboard about foot wide extended
over the wheels on either side of the
pool length of the wagon thus forming
the foundation for a large and roomy
Second Story which were placed up beds
under the spring seats were compartments
in which restored many articles useful
for the journey although they sounded
fancy not everyone was a fan of the Reed
wagons in fact the other people resented
them for two reasons one they were quite
show-offish as if James Reid was
constantly saying look at me I'm richer
than you than two they were heavy and
slowed down the whole Wagon Train they
needed an extra pair of oxen to pull
them and this was on relatively even
ground just imagine how much of a burden
they would become if they had to travel
over rough mountainous terrain but don't
worry they probably wouldn't have to
probably right Malden convenience is
aside the past six weeks of the trip
went smoothly and the group managed to
Traverse 650 miles of Country Crossing
most of what's now Southeast and Wyoming
until they reached Fort Laramie this leg
of the journey was the same regardless
of whether you intended to take the
Oregon Trail the California Trail or
some crazy experimental new trail that
was supposed to be the best of the bunch
but eventually they reached the
crossroads and it was decision time did
they stay on the well-traveled path and
follow the Oregon Trail to Fort Hall in
modern day Idaho or did they take the
unknown Hastings cart off and supposedly
shave a few hundred miles off their
route while also ending up in Northern
California well let's just say they
chose poorly
[Music]
on July the 20th most of the Wagon train
went on its merry way to Fort Hall
leaving behind the members of the
ill-fated Donna party their numbers had
swirled past the original 31 who left
Springfield Illinois the party now
included 87 people who were convinced by
Reed and the donors that they knew what
they were doing we're obviously not
going to mention everyone we'll just say
that notable additions included the
graves family the breans The Murphys The
keyserbergs the Eddies the mccutcheans
and a few Bachelor men who either
traveled alone or tagged along with the
aforementioned families they elected
George Donner as debt leader which is
why the group is remembered as the
Donner Party Reid might have been the
driving force behind the trip but it
seems that people simply didn't like him
that much they found him too
ostentatious and autocratic compared to
the more calm and more peaceful Donna
anyway their first stop was a Fort
Bridger a trading post that represented
not only the beginning of the Hastings
cut off but also the party's last chance
to restock on supplies before coming out
on the other side this was the moment
that the group truly became doomed
unbeknownst to read or any of the other
Travelers a journalist named Edwin
Bryant scouted Hastings of shortcut on
Horseback and concluded that it was a
terrible route that should not be
undertaken in wagons under any
circumstances he even wrote back to warn
everyone but nobody in the Donna party
ever saw the letters Reed later accused
Bridger and his partner Vasquez of oh
withholding the letters on purpose to
get them to go through with the trip if
the Hastings cut off were to become the
new standard route for settlers headed
to California that would have meant a
lot of extra business for their trading
post on July the 31st the party set off
on their faithful Journey Through the
Hastings cut off heading towards the
southern end of the Great Salt Lake
after only a few days it became apparent
that this new route was not all it was
cracked up to be but the group pressed
on at least until they reached the
Wasatch mountains up until this point
Reed had acted as a guide following
directions carved into trees by none
other than Lansford Hastings himself the
guy who got them into this mess in the
first place initially Hastings promised
to join the group but he hooked up with
a different party at Fort Bridger and
left a few weeks ahead of The Donna Reed
party their faction was known as the
Harlem party and the reason that you've
never heard of them was that they
actually arrived at their destination
albeit sick from thirst and exhaustion
although this is speculation it wouldn't
be outlandish to suggest that Hastings
might have been using these groups as
guinea pigs trying to discover the best
route through his eponymous shortcut
because even though he had found a
viable route through the mountains with
the Harlan young party he left
instructions for Reed to travel a
different way with his group promising
him that it was a better solution it
wasn't you'll be surprised to hear the
Donner Party traveled at a snail's pace
covering less than two miles a day and
this while all the healthy men in the
group worked around the clock to clear
the road of debris for the wagons on
August 25th the party had its first
casualty 25 year old Merchant Luke
Halloran Halloran was one of the
Bachelors who joined the trip and
realistically there were slim chance of
him ever making it to California since
he was suffering from consumption or
tuberculosis as we call it today it took
the Donner Party 18 days to travel 30
miles but in late August they were out
at the mountains and finally had nothing
but smooth sailing until they reached
their destination
just kidding of course they now had to
cross the Great Salt Lake Desert one of
the most inhospitable areas of the
United States devoid of drinking water
or grass to feed the animal someone just
is an added bonus the ground was moist
and brittle making it very easy for the
wagon wheels to sink into the salt crust
it was just happy days all around for
everybody involved but at least by this
point everyone realized that they'd been
sold a bum steer with the Hastings cut
off but don't worry things are about to
get worse
foreign
on September the 26 1846 the Donner
Party reached the Humboldt River
completing the crossing of the Hastings
cut off no other people died during the
ordeal but they lost dozens of animals
and were forced to leave many wagons
behind at this point they rejoined the
traditional California Trail but the
situation was far from sunshine and
rainbows they were a month behind
schedule and the Donner party was now
trapped in a Race Against Time needing
to cross the Sierra Nevada before the
weather turned sour tensions were hot
and they boiled over on October 5th when
a fire broke out between James Reed and
the teamster of the graves family John
Snyder everyone had different opinions
on who started it and why but the result
was the same Reed plunged his knife into
Snyder's chest killing him in minutes
there was some discussion of hanging
read right then and there but eventually
the group decided to banish him letting
him fend for himself Reed agreed to his
punishment as long as they continued to
take care of his family at this point we
can firmly say that the Donner Party had
disintegrated they weren't one cohesive
unit anymore just a bunch of people who
happened to share the same Misfortune
their survival instincts kicked in so
they splinted off into smaller groups
looking out for only themselves and to
hell with anyone else case in point on
October the 8th Louis casenberg kicked
an older Belgian companion named hard
Coop out of his wagon telling him he
even needed to walk or to die none of
the others wanted to take him so the old
man fell behind the group and was never
seen again a few days later another man
named wallfinger was killed ostensibly
by peyote Native Americans who
irregularly raided their party for
livestock although he might have been
murdered by two of his traveling
Companions and then a week after that a
member of the Murphy family William Pike
was shot and killed in an accident
that's four deaths in less than a month
and before the group even entered the
Sierra Nevada it was becoming
increasingly clear that many of them
were not going to make it to California
but just when things were at their
bleakest a tiny Speck of Hope pierced
through the dark shroud it was Charles
Stanton one of the men who rode ahead of
the group in search of help he had
reached sata's fault and had returned
with seven pack meals loaded with food
as well as two my walk helpers named
Luis and Salvador this gave everyone
enough confidence that maybe just maybe
they could make one last person cross
the mountains before getting snowed in
foreign
wasn't expected until the middle of
November but hey everything else had
gone to the dogs I mean why would this
be any different the snow came in early
and when the group reached Truckee Lake
they encountered a blocked pass that had
completely been snowed in they had no
choice they had to Winter in the
mountains both the pass and the lake
were renamed after Donna to commemorate
the fact that half the party never made
it out there alive around 60 people
camped by Donna Lake taking advantage of
some run-down cabins that had been built
there by earlier Travelers the remaining
20 or so consisting of the Donner
families and their helpers had to make
Camp further down the trail by Alder
Creek because they axle on their wagon
broke by December Food Supplies were
almost exhausted people began dying of
malnutrition While others survived by
boiling oxide and horse bones every now
and then catching a mouse or some other
Road and represented a variable Feast
William Eddy was briefly the hero of the
camp when he hunted a bear but even that
was quickly devoured until there was
nothing left something needed to be done
or else everyone was going to Starved
death by Springtime in mid December a
group was formed they were called the
Snowshoe party because they improvised
some snowshoes out of oxbows and hides
but historians later bestowed upon the
group The much more appropriate name for
lawn hope it consisted of 17 of the most
resilient people in the camp men women
even a few children they were going to
try and make it over the past on foot
and get help it was a desperate plan but
one that was destined for failure nobody
in the group had the strength experience
or supplies to make such a journey they
got lost in the snow and after two days
with no food a man named Patrick Dolan
was the first to say it they needed to
eat someone otherwise they would all die
the question was who they talked about
drawing lots to see who would be the
Unlucky sacrifice or maybe about having
a duel eventually they reasoned that a
one of them would drop dead of natural
causes soon enough and they would not
have to kill anybody but it was true a
Teamster named Antonio died not long
after that followed by the graves family
patriarch Franklin Graves but a blizzard
forced the others to leave their bodies
behind then Patrick Dolan died after
running naked into the snow did
Delirious for hypothermia and then the
youngest of the group 13 year old Emil
Murphy also perished the survivors held
out as long as they could but after five
days of starvation they were mad with
Hunger more animal than human and so
they crossed that line most people would
find inconceivable and they ate Patrick
Dolan averting their gaze from one
another as they cut strips of his flesh
and roasted them on the far the two my
walk guides Louis and Salvador were the
only ones who refused to partake oddly
enough this turned them into targets
that could be killed for food after all
even in the deepest reaches of Despair
racism was alive and well so the group
reasoned that the push came to shove it
was better to kill two Native Americans
than two whites William Eddie was the
only one not okay with it so he warned
Lewis and Salvador and told them to run
away they did but without any food they
didn't make it very far a few days later
the Snowshoe party which now consisted
of Two Men and five women Came Upon The
Mao grind still alive but hanging on by
only a threat one of the two surviving
men William Foster killed both of them
now the group weren't just cannibals
they were murderers
foreign
their actions heinous and gruesome as
they may be worked and on January the
19th what was left of the Snowshoe party
reached the Johnson Ranch in the
Sacramento Valley after regaining his
strength William Eddie continued to
sata's Fort where he informed every one
of their plight he discovered that James
Reid had also made it out of the
mountains and attempted to organize his
own rescue but both men encountered the
same problem in another example of
spectacular timing in April 1846 right
after the Donna party left Illinois the
Mexican-American War had started in
California back then was still a part of
Mexico the colonel at huddersfort needed
all his soldiers and it wasn't until
February that he could spare a few men
to launch a rescue operation and of
course that wasn't all it was still
winter and Donna Lake was snowed in so
Rescuers couldn't use any wagons instead
there to hike and climb bringing only
whatever supplies they could carry and
they couldn't take back everyone at once
so they'd have to do it in stages the
first relief team consisting of seven
men led by a William Eddy reached the
camp on February the 18th they found at
least a dozen dead and most survivors
were in a State of Shock or delirium
there was evidence of cannibalism here
as well although the survivors came
conflicting accounts over who ate who
same thing at the Donna camp near Alder
Creek it seemed that the Donnas suffered
the most losses out of everyone both
Donna brothers died as did their wives
and a few of their children the only
adult who made it out of their alive was
a Teamster named Noah Jones the relief
team took 23 people back with them
leaving food for the others to be
rescued later even so they weren't out
of the woods yet some of the evacuees
died on Route and other campers perished
while still waiting to be rescued it
wasn't until April and three additional
relief teams later that all the
survivors were evacuated from their Camp
of death the last rescue party found
only one person still living Lewis
katarberg allegedly surrounded by human
parts in a sight too Dreadful to be put
on record even though the previous team
left him plenty of food he was suspected
of murdering Tams and honor and and not
just eating but also robbing her and
although many if not all survivors ate
human flesh the newspapers turned
kesselberg into the True Villain of the
story but just like the rest of the
Donner Party faced no legal consequences
for his actions and lived out his days
as a free man be it one with the
reputation of a killer cannibal so 89
people went into those mountains 48
people came out the snow and famine took
the rest
foreign